[Música]
hola bienvenidos a la revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo el aumento en
el flujo de emigrantes que busca llegar
a estados unidos llevó a la casa blanca
a confiar en que puede persuadirlos de
no emprender ese viaje el gobierno de
joe biden inició una serie de campañas
con mensajes en redes sociales y
estaciones de radio enfocadas en países
de américa latina sin embargo la
efectividad de esta iniciativa es
cuestionada ya que el acceso a internet
en estos territorios es limitado
empezamos la casablanca aplicó una nueva
forma de intentar detener la ola
migratoria que busca llegar a eeuu a
través de su frontera sur las redes
sociales y la radio la administración de
joe biden dijo haber lanzado una masiva
campaña con la que busca persuadir a los
migrantes de que sus fronteras están
cerradas y que no es tiempo de viajar a
este país a través de su cuenta de
twitter facebook e instagram las
embajadas de eeuu en guatemala honduras
y el salvador por ejemplo lanzaron todo
tipo de mensajes por medio del numeral
un viaje en vano han promovido
fotografías animaciones comics
os instando a la gente a no perder el
tiempo ni dinero han advertido sobre los
peligros que enfrentan al emprender la
travesía ya sea por el clima extremo por
las condiciones inhumanas que sufrirían
en manos de traficantes de personas o el
solo hecho de ser sorprendidos por las
autoridades estadounidenses y ser
devueltos a sus países de origen
estamos adoptando enfoques creativos en
diferentes países para asegurarnos de
llegar a las personas conocerlas dónde
están a modo de ejemplo la embajada en
san salvador el cómic y el programa de
animación llamado oscuro busca disuadir
la migración irregular abordando la
violencia como un motor el contenido
enfocado en la reducción de la violencia
llevó a 240 mil jóvenes salvadoreños en
la audiencia objetiva 2 en jones al
behrends en de charquero aliens y es que
la situación en la frontera sur de eeuu
se agudiza el número de personas que ha
intentado ingresar al país ha ido en
aumento los detractores de joe biden
dicen que el cambio en las duras
políticas de su antecesor donald trump
generó un efecto llamada
es decir que llevó a los migrantes a
creer que las puertas del país están
abiertas para todo el mundo de acuerdo
con un reciente reporte de la oficina de
aduanas y protección fronteriza sólo en
febrero las autoridades encontraron a
más de 100.000 migrantes en la frontera
con mexico un aumento significativo si
se compara con los más de 36 mil casos
de febrero de 2020 más de 76.000 en 2019
y más de 36 mil en 2018 el alto flujo
migratorio
emergencia provocada por el cob y 19 y
el hacinamiento en las instalaciones
fronterizas donde una multitud de
personas espera una respuesta para
definir su situación pese a ello la
administración bailén se ha negado a
calificarla como una crisis
de acuerdo con james aquí la secretaria
de prensa de la casa blanca desde el día
en que vaivén tomó posición se han
colocado unos 17.118 anuncios en radio
en guatemala honduras y el salvador
países que integran el llamado triángulo
del norte y desde donde sale la mayoría
de emigrantes esta publicidad con la que
pretenden disuadir a quienes buscan el
sueño americano se emitió en español
portugués y seis lenguas indígenas
estos anuncios segundos aquí se
reprodujeron en 33 estaciones de radio y
alcanzaron un total de 15 millones de
personas por otro lado se desplegó una
campaña en redes sociales como facebook
e instagram con un total de 589 anuncios
que habrían llegado a más de 26 millones
de personas y de acuerdo con la casa
blanca se enfocaron en usuarios que se
ajustan al perfil de posibles migrantes
pero cuando se le preguntó sobre la
efectividad de la campaña hasta aquí
dijo que es difícil contar el número de
personas que no llega al país y que es
un número que nunca van a tener
implementar campañas a través de redes
sociales en países como guatemala
honduras y el salvador podría ser una
tarea difícil las cifras más recientes y
detalladas sobre él
a penetración de internet y redes
móviles son pocas
un reporte de 2017 del banco mundial
indica por ejemplo que en guatemala solo
el 41 por ciento de la población usa
internet seguido del salvador con el 34
por ciento y honduras con un 32 por
ciento basada en datos de 2019 la
comisión económica para américa latina y
el caribe reveló que el 66.7 por ciento
de los habitantes de la región tiene
conexión a internet mientras que el
resto tiene acceso limitado o no lo
tiene
teniendo en cuenta estos datos surge un
cuestionamiento que tan efectivas
resultarían estas campañas en internet
se lo preguntamos a natalia va nules
kubot time directora asociada del
programa internacional de la
organización migration policy institute
creo que estas campañas asumen que la
gente está tomando decisiones a falta de
información y que si sólo se provee esa
información se puede cambiar el
comportamiento cambiar las percepciones
y ya está la gente siquiera viendo esta
información si entra en contacto con
ella la cree la encuentra creíble
si no tienen smartphones con redes
sociales o no están escuchando un canal
de radio en particular será una
inversión malgastado
los medios de comunicación analizan las
acciones del gobierno en estos
territorios para enfrentar la situación
mientras la cadena voice of america dice
que la administración de bailén está
reaccionando a la evidencia de que las
condiciones en la frontera entre eeuu y
méxico
buenas el portal businessinsider titula
que la administración bailen las da una
campaña en las redes sociales para
persuadir a los migrantes de que no
regresen a eeuu a medida que se
intensifica su crisis fronteriza the
wall street journal se refirió a los
mensajes promocionados diciendo que la
administración bailén dañó su propio
caso durante los primeros días del
gobierno al ofrecer a los migrantes un
mensaje contradictorio que si bien no
debían intentar el viaje la ayuda estaba
en camino agrega que según expertos que
ese matiz se perdió en la mayoría de los
migrantes
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra misión de
nuestro programa lo puedes hacer a
través de nuestra página web www puntos
24 punto com
[Música]